is there room for both Kenya and Nene in
this friend circle I hope so
well first of all how are you doing
being trapped inside with your daughter
Mike's daughters Mike everybody's in one
half and all girl friend okay we somehow
in here so one man and three other
females it is been a learning lesson
we've had to have a couple of different
house meetings we had to lay down some
ground rules we had just you know make
short assignments because apparently
they think that they don't have anything
eat all the food sleep all day and make
tick tops of course you're going to come
into this house and you're going to
clean and if anything come up missing in
my house I promise you you won't come up
missing I think we've made some pretty
impressive tick tops I'm just saying
I haven't seen everybody said about
anything why wouldn't you have a
bachelor with me that's my point that
it's like you're in your feelings but
beyond Andy what was the question she
said that she didn't like it that you
said but I got busy so Hayley and Ashley
they were like well or does that might
do it
so Mike just stepped in for me little
did I know he was going to kill it I
don't think I could have ever done it as
well as he did so you know God doesn't
make mistakes
I mean is this testing your relationship
at all no time apart oh for sure this is
the ultimate test right now because
here's the thing if we get into an
argument and I get mad at Mike about
something normally the old before the
corona virus quarantine Cynthia Bailey
would go check in a hotel I'd be like
you know what
I don't see her tonight I would go and
drive myself from Porter Ranch to
Berkeley Hills and kick myself into a
nice little hotel and be mation now I
have to still sleep in the same thing in
the same house and I'm just happy to go
out for any reason at this point but yes
things have changed pressure definitely
been tested but you know it's not it
forced us to this is kind of like what
it would really be like to be married
and like work from home together like I
take my hat off to anyone who is married
and work at home every day and see their
partner every single day because you
guys have to realize Mike and I are no
long distance relationship and even if
we weren't with both of our careers I
travel a lot to work and so does he so
we don't see each other every single day
morning moon night breakfast lunch and
dinner but now we see each other we see
each other we good and the same kids
[Laughter]
like wow yeah well you guys had teas
that you are thinking of a 10 10 20
wedding date has this whole situation
put any snags and planning well we've
had to really think about it a little
bit we did speak with our wedding
planner to see what our options were in
case we had to postpone it I'll move the
date back because quite honestly you
know at this point we don't know when
you know we don't know what's going on
we don't know when people are going to
be able to go back to work or if they're
going to be able to go back to work even
if they still have jobs I don't know if
people will be able you know a lot of my
friends are from out of town I don't
know if they'll be able to afford to
come in at this point like I just really
don't know and or even be in the spirit
to go like this has been a very I mean
hopefully people are gonna come out and
want to celebrate and just go everyw
everywhere they can go but I
really don't know Bryce it's kind of
concerning because you still have the
date holding but we did speak to the
venue and a wedding planner to see where
our options were if we needed to move it
back because we all know this morning we
can't even know so I can't even worry
about Nick ceasing it we just I'm just
trying to get past the reunion whenever
we get to that I know it was that was
sad to hear and then it was very sad to
hear that Andy is battling the
coronavirus so that's a whole other
thing to know like seriously and I was
the last one to see him actually I was
the last well last one the last
Housewives of Atlanta and see him I saw
him a couple of weeks ago and everybody
was fine actually I've been texting with
him actually sent him the video of my
plan he really enjoyed it he actually
posted on this story too but yeah so he
said he's feeling much better by the way
very good to hear yeah you brought up
Noelle's girlfriend yes she decided to
go public with her girl in the middle of
all this well it's kind of like you know
she's here
you know she's originally from Baltimore
so you know we didn't want to just feel
like you know left out so we're home we
have food we have supplies we have
gloves and I'm clean you're like me I
met when I tell you I'm cooking and
cleaning around this house like I've
literally gone from a Real Housewife of
Atlanta to just a real damn housewife
like I'm not even kidding you like it's
it's crazy I was like okay but yeah we
just wanted to include you know Alexis
and you know it's been great so you know
it's cool like we didn't want her to
just be stuff for ourselves yeah a very
intense meet the family moment no yeah
well this is attest to their
relationship as well I don't think
that's me
we'll see who comes out on the upside
we will see it's a test from God for
sure we have some rapid-fire questions
rapping to everybody that we're checking
in on like how they're keeping busy so
what are you watching on TV what are you
binging um Mike and I just finished
watching plungers so good now he's
watching the shy
I watched madam CJ Walker story I
watched that story and then I just
watched the banker which was great
on Sundays for Housewives of Atlanta
which is really good about you know I
was a certain size for my reunion dress
when this started let's just say I hope
that I can actually still fit it by the
time we get to 3/8 because I know I
always joke about relationship week now
I think I gotta add some corona week
some Quarantine weight or whatever you
want to call it but yeah mom again think
over here
[Music]
it's like really gonna work out
actually I'm better than okay harder
then you know all the knows but the
trolls you just put on music you put you
set it and you just start dancing like a
lunatic and that's been helpful
it's like stressful this whole thing
like this has never happened before and
it's kind of like you feel like you need
to be doing something you're trying to
be productive and then like part of me
is like okay I'm going to organize the
pantry I'm gonna organize my closet I'm
gonna go clean up the garage and the
important is like you know what I don't
know what is gonna end I'm gonna enjoy
this because I never get to sleep in
just sleep all day get up eat go back
like that's my life right you know say
you know at least a good week of it is
it's kind of good but now I'm like I'm
ready to go back to working go anywhere
what is the routine are you getting up
and getting dressed every day or is it
just like I'm in pajamas that Ben that's
not couple days ago I'm like today it
was probably one of the first days
actually made an effort and put some
makeup on I have I went from first I was
trying to make a little bit of an effort
and at least put on sweats now it's a
strictly pajamas and once he's at this
point it's like what's the point Mike
it's like but everybody looks a mess so
it's like all right the only time we
actually try to pull ourselves together
is to do a tick-tock yeah all right well
we got to talk Atlanta which thank God
we still get to have every Sunday in
this crazy time yes yes how are you
feeling now that the seasons kind of
winding down how do you feel about the
season overall that I started the season
thinking it's gonna be the worst season
in my entire life because coming up the
reunion that I came off I knew that you
know I just basically was like okay I
get to fight Nene the whole freaking
season which is not fun for me because
at the end of the day no matter what you
know I still have love for you know what
I mean we don't ever have to be best
friends or
sisters any of that stuff but there is
still love there for her so anyway said
I'll have to say I felt like you know by
the time we talked and you know we're
around each other in the group and
everything I felt like we are in a good
place
Wheatly certainly I don't know if it'll
ever be like it was and that's okay but
I feel like we are in a we kind of left
it in a respectful place and I'm not
saying you know she might not tomato
Lachey here and here whatever and that's
fine you know I'm used to shape I'm a
real housewife along so that just kind
of comes with it but I felt like all my
relationships with all of the girls I
got some stuff I gotta like get straight
at the reunion but for the most part I
don't think any of it is beyond repair
what do you want to tackle at the
Reunion when that fire when you finally
get to do it what do you want to work
out there well you know I want to
definitely try to figure out try to get
to the bottom snake gate what that was
all about because that you know that
whole you know theory this whole snake a
thing put out the perception of that I
was you know doing something bad to my
friend that I wasn't doing you know what
I mean yeah like when we were friends
I've never you know said anything no it
was always praise if anything I was like
oh you're like of course then it was
like oh you're Nene's lap dog whatever
you know people never thought I ever
want to get stirred with anything which
it's not even true but anyway the point
is you know I don't like I Know Who I am
you know I know my intentions I know I'm
a good person
for someone to intentionally put out
like oh you know to imply that I'm like
somebody that I'm not I'm not saying I'm
perfect and you know if I feel like
you're coming for me yeah I'm gonna
respond as well so but it's only like at
this point if we're not friends then if
you say so then I'm gonna say something
if I say something I'm not mad at you
since it is what it is it's called we're
not friends in you and we don't like
each other so you
as big say about Vietnam has some things
to say about you but it was never when
we were friends you know I'm a very
loyal person and you know that means a
lot to me you know for people to
understand that I mean there's a reason
that I'm one of the only friends on the
show that everybody ends up in the damn
French franc all the time because
obviously my friendship matters because
people actually want to deal with it and
fight over it yeah you know I get a lot
of stuff about Kenya who you know Kenya
is my friend I'm not saying I agree with
everything that Kenya does on the show
but you know there's a lot of things
that kingís does off the show that you
know that has proven to me her
friendship to me and one of the things
that you will not ever see Kenya Moore
do is attack me you know in the press
and say crazy stuff that that's not what
Kenya debts some other people do it but
that's not what Kenya does so it's like
how you are on the show and off to show
you like balance all that out and be
like okay this is a friendship worth you
know saving it thrown away yeah we um we
talked to Nene probably about a month
ago and she said similar thing like
you're in a good place that's why I'm
never gonna be back where it was and the
only way to get it back to that place
she said would be to take the show out
of the equation maybe you know what I
don't disagree with that you know when I
see Nene outside of the show like I ran
out right into an airport not that long
ago I mean I was like oh gosh they say
to me I should act like I don't see her
that's like this is so stupid like I
work with this woman this is someone I
used to spend a lot of time with so I
just marched right over there it was
like hi how are you it was totally fine
look you can call it whatever you want
so I just call it respect I see you I'm
going to say hi am I going to invite
your ass over dinner no but I'm going
I'm going to say hi so this is what it
is I think it's so stupid to see someone
that you work with and you have a
sisterhood with however dysfunctional
and don't acknowledge that person I'm
not doing that I'm too old for that
well we've seen one of those
dysfunctional relationships all season
long between
and Kenya and I went back into the
midseason trailer to kind of pick apart
what haven't we've seen yet and like
they have another moment at what I'm
guessing is the finale party yeah they
do have another moment there is room for
both Kenya and Nene in this friend
circle
I hope so I mean for me I I'm in a good
place with Nene and I'm in a good place
with Kenya and I'm not going to not be
friends with Kenya because Nene and I'm
not gonna be friends with Nene because I
can't go I'm not going you know what I'm
saying I'm not gonna know ladies because
they don't like each other I'm just not
gonna do it now does it suck to be in
the middle of that yeah especially on a
TV show you know in real life I could
just keep them apart on the show we have
to all see each other and you know I am
good with showing loved boats and
whatever they have going on you know
they're just gonna have to work it out
you know that the fans were very
surprised to meet Ken we learned there's
Kenya and then there's Ben as you make
of because you got to see that firsthand
kind of oh yeah because I've been around
Kenya and Mark you know you know away
from the girls as well you know look
Kenya is Kenya you know she is her own
person she's independent thinker she's
smart as hell you know she Shady's hell
you know to be like she is a big
personality but I will say you know on
and off the show you know in
relationships not just with her husband
but particularly with Mark she
definitely is a little bit more on the
submissive side she is very much like oh
you know she's on the phone with me
she's like Oh mark I'd be home in ten
minutes I got to get a phone I get her
make sure this food is ready I gotta
make sure the house is clean I gotta
make sure I look like she is like really
like wants to be a good wife and you
know there's that can is definitely her
more submissive you know wacky side okay
I know we only have a few episodes left
of what still to come this season what
are you excited for the fans to see oh
goodness
the finale was you know it was great to
come together to celebrate for King
Lee's new baby blaze for a shower so it
was great to do that but it just went so
far to the left that it just wasn't as
enjoyable as he could have been I know
my ass ain't in a hot seat no more
progressive cities and so I won't be in
hot seating Warren to Lou you so I'm
enjoying yeah
[Music]